PROFESSOR: One of
the things you will
be thinking about
in the homework
is the definition of
gauge-invariant observables.
So an operator O is a
gauge-invariant observable--
gauge environment
observable-- if, see,
under a gauged
transformation, O can change.
The operator can change under
a gauged transformation.
You'd say, oh, but isn't it
supposed to be gauge-invariant?
But, well, it's not
quite the operator itself
that is gauge-invariant.
It is its expectation value.
So you should have that
psi prime of O prime psi
prime is equal to psi O psi.
So the operator may change.
And that's OK.
The wave function
will change as well.
So the question is that
if you put the new wave
function and the new operator
and you find the expectation
value, do you get
the same thing?
That's what you really can ask.
You cannot ask more than that.
And you will see very funny
things when you do this.
You will see that
this operator, P,
the momentum operator
that you like,
that you find has been
intuitive for you so far,
is not gauge-invariant.
You cannot compute the
expectation value of it
and expect something physical.
It's not gauge-invariant.
The thing that is
gauge-invariant is P minus q
over c A--
is gauge-invariant.
So it's some small
calculations you will do.
In order to get the
gauge-invariant operator,
you do, in general, have
to put in a dependence.
That's the funny thing.
So this thing will not
be gauge-invariant.
And, you know,
it's almost obvious
that P is not gauge-invariant.
Why?
Because P, under a
gauge transformation--
well, the gauge
transformation, say,
change A, change phi
prime, change psi.
But it doesn't say change P. So
in the gauge transformation, P
goes to P.
But then let's look at
psi prime P psi prime.
Is it equal to psi P psi?
Well, here you
have that psi prime
is psi times e to the minus
i q lambda over h bar c.
You have P here.
And e to the i q
lambda over h bar c.
Psi prime-- no, psi.
That's the left-hand side.
And this P is such that
it takes derivatives.
And lambda depends on space.
So this is going to
give you something.
This is not going to cancel.
This is not going to cancel,
and therefore the left-hand side
is not going to be equal
to the right-hand side.
The faces don't go
across each other.
So therefore, there it is.
P is no good.
Not intuitive, not
physical, not observable.
It's a very strange
thing that once you
put electromagnetic fields,
P, the canonical generator
of translation, loses
its privileged status.
Not anymore we can
think of P so easily.
And look, however.
If you had here P
minus qA, P minus qA
is precisely the kind
of thing that you
can move the face
across, and you
will see that then it works.
You get something to simplify,
and it's all very nice.
So gauge invariance makes
for funny things to happen.
I want to do an example that
illustrates quantization,
another pretty surprising thing.
So we have quite a few
things to do today.
So let me try to do this
magnetic fields example.
Magnetic field on a torus.
So we've talked about
what is a circle.
And we say a circle is the
line with the identification
x equal x plus L. So the point 0
is identified with the point L.
And that's a circle.
This line on this point
is the same as this one,
so you return.
A torus that we use--
so, this is a circle--
a torus, which is
something that we sometimes
think of like this,
is, on the other hand,
an identification of
the following kind.
Here is the x-axis.
Here is the y-axis.
Here is Lx.
Here is Ly.
And we say that any point xy is
identified with x plus Ly Lx,
and every point xy is identified
with xy plus Ly, which
is to say that any point
with some value of x
is identified with a point
with x increasing by Lx.
So this line is supposed
to be glued to this line.
And this line is supposed
to be glued to that line.
So this is identified
and this is identified.
Perhaps the most intuitive
way of thinking of this
is take this strip, take
these two sides, glue them.
Now you have a cylinder.
And now you're supposed to
glue this end to the first end.
So you glue them like that, and
you form something like this.
So here is a torus.
Now we try to put the
magnetic field on this torus.
So you could say,
well, this is x and y.
There is a torus.
There's the z-direction.
Let's put the
magnetic field that
goes through the torus
in the z-direction.
B z.
B in the z-direction.
And we'll put a constant
one, B constant.
So it's time-independent
and space-independent.
And then you say, OK, let's
look at my Maxwell's equations.
Divergence of B equals 0.
B is constant.
Good.
Curl of B is related to current.
There's no current.
Plus dE dt,
displacement current.
There's no electric field.
Good equation.
Curl of E is minus dB dt, no E.
There's no problem, obviously.
So B, for any
constant value of B,
it satisfies
Maxwell's equations.
So any constant
value of B should
be an allowed magnetic field.
Or so we would think,
because it actually is not.
So why does it go
wrong, this intuition?
We'll see.
But let's put an assumption.
The assumption is that we're
doing quantum mechanics,
and there exists a
particle with charge.
And I'll call it this time q.
I'll just--
So if we're doing
quantum mechanics,
and there exists a
particle of charge q,
I need potentials to describe
the quantum mechanics.
I need an A field
to describe this.
So I know B is consistent,
and it makes sense,
and we can use it,
if and only if I
can find a vector potential.
So our task is to find a
vector potential on this torus.
Well, at first sight that
doesn't sound too difficult.
You can say, all right, let's
find the vector potential.
That's easy to find an A such
that curl of A is equal to B.
So B z is dx A y minus dy A x.
So let's simplify my life.
Let's take A y to
be equal to B z,
and let's call this magnetic
field B0, the constant value
B0.
Constant.
So A y would be equal to B0
times x, and A x would be 0.
OK.
That's it.
Look.
A y is equal to B0 x.
So I take the
derivative dx of A y.
I get B0.
dy of A x is 0.
Perfect.
All done, we would say.
You found the A y.
But there is a problem with this
[? A i. ?] What is the problem?
If this is a torus,
it means these points
are the same as these points.
So I should have,
the vector potential
here must be the same as
the vector potential there.
Because it is, after
all, the same point.
You're gluing the surface.
But, OK, this point and
this point differ by y.
And this vector potential
doesn't depend on y.
So, phew.
That's good.
A is well-defined because it
has the same value anywhere here
as anywhere there.
So I can write it as A y of
x, y plus L y at any point x.
And y plus L y is the
same thing as A y of xy.
So that's very good.
But we're going to run
into trouble in the second
now, because the A y should be
the same here and here, too.
Because that's also the
same points in the torus.
This line is
identified with this.
So when I change x by L
x, A y should not change.
And here it seems like A y at x
plus L x, and the same point y,
is not the same as A y at xy.
And this is a torus, so this
point, x plus L x and y and y
should be the same.
So this vector potential is
not the same here as here.
So, actually, this vector
potential doesn't look good.
You thought you could write
the magnetic field in terms
of a vector potential,
but this vector potential
doesn't seem to
live on the torus.
It's just not a
well-defined magnetic vector
potential in the torus.
It doesn't have the same
value here and here.
So in principle,
we're not through.
We're not out of the woods here.
We have not been able to find
a good vector potential yet.
But here, the gauge
transformations
come a little to the rescue.
When you work with
vector potentials,
you don't really need
that the vector potential
be the same here as here.
It is enough if the
vector potential here
and here, which
is the same point,
they differ by a
gauge transformation.
So the vector potential
is a subtle object.
Here is the torus.
In one part of the
torus it has a formula.
In the other part, it may
look like it's not consistent.
But you can use
another formula related
by a gauge transformation.
So this vector
potential here is OK
if I manage to show that
what I get on this side
is just the gauge transformation
of what I was getting here.
So physically
these are the same.
And yes, you have a unique
configuration on the torus
if the vector potential here is
gauge-equivalent to the vector
potential there.
So let's try to do that.
So, gauge transformations
to the rescue.
OK.
A y of x plus Lxy.
I want it to be a
gauge transformation
of the field at A y xy.
So remember, A prime was
A plus gradient of lambda.
So I'm going to write this
as A at the same point, which
is xy--
it's physically the same point--
plus the gradient of lambda, in
this case would be dy lambda.
OK.
Now we have to find
the gauge parameter.
To show that they're
gauge-equivalent here and here,
I must find the gauge parameter.
That's the lambda.
So let's do the formula here.
This is B0.
There's a formula
here, B0 times x.
So x plus Lx times x plus
Lx is equal to B0 times
x plus dy lambda.
So I cancel here and I get
B0 Lx is equal to dy lambda.
OK.
All right.
So, well, it seems that
we're succeeding again,
against all odds.
And we could take lambda, for
example, to be B0 Lx times y.
And that would be
our gauge parameter.
OK.
So are we happy already?
Have we shown that
everything is working?
Well, there's still a problem.
This time the gauge parameter
doesn't seem to be well-defined
on the torus as
well when I change--
you know, we didn't have
problems with y here.
We had problems with x.
When we tried to fix it with
x, we find the gauge parameter.
But the gauge parameter
doesn't seem to have--
it does have problems with y.
It's not the same at this
point and at this point.
Because at those points,
y differs by L y,
and the gauge parameter,
again, doesn't quite
seem to live on the torus.
It seems like an endless
amount of complication.
But we're near the
end of the road now.
The thing that comes to our
rescue is that lambda, in fact,
doesn't quite have to
be that well-defined.
Why?
Because the gauge transformation
of the charged particle
says that you need to do i
Q over hc lambda times psi.
That's how you do
gauge transformations.
And in fact, this, remember,
this is the U thing.
And even though we write
A prime as A D lambda,
this term can be
written in terms
of U. U is the master quantity
that has all the information.
In fact, D lambda is roughly
U minus 1 gradient of U,
up to a series of factors.
So everything
depends on U. So we
don't have to worry too
much if lambda is not
well-defined on the torus.
What has to be
well-defined on the torus
is U, the exponential of lambda.
And that, it's a saver, because
U, now, is e to the i q.
Lambda is B0 Lxy over h bar c.
That's U. And U will be
well-defined on the torus
if, when you change y plus y
plus L y, this doesn't change.
And for that, this whole thing,
when you change y by L y,
must change by a factor of 2 pi.
So if-- you see, you're
living dangerously with this.
It just doesn't want
to exist on a torus.
But if this happens to
be equal to 2 pi n--
so if you have q B0 Lx Ly
over hc equal to 2 pi n,
everything is OK.
That thing, when you
change y for y plus L y,
this whole exponent
changes by 2 pi n.
And i times 2 pi n is 1.
So U is well-defined
on the torus.
So we're almost there.
Here it is.
B0-- there is a quantization.
B0 times the area of the
torus is equal to 2 pi n--
pi n-- hc over q n.
So you cannot have
arbitrary magnetic field.
The magnetic field is such
that the flux is quantized.
So here is the
illustration of an example
I wanted to mention
from the beginning,
that if you have a magnetic
field that solves Maxwell's
equations, you're not done.
You have to find potentials.
And sometimes there are
funny things happening.
And in particular,
here is the funny thing
that has happened
here, is that in order
to have a well-defined vector
potential on the torus,
you've been forced to
quantize the magnetic field.
And B0 times A is
equal to phi, the flux.
And this flux is a multiple
of this quantity, which
is sometimes called
the quantum of flux,
the least possible flux.
n, the flux quantum.
So this flux quantum, it is
a famous number, in fact.
I have it somewhere here.
Somewhere in my notes.
Yes, here it is.
Phi 0 for electrons,
for q equal to e--
phi 0-- these are
units you seldom use.
But it's about 2.068 times
10 to the minus 15 webers.
Who knows what a weber is?
Or 2.068 times 10 to
the minus 7 Maxwells.
Anybody know what a Maxwell is?
OK, a weber is a unit of flux.
It's tesla times meter squared.
That's far too big.
The Maxwell, it's a
more natural thing.
Maxwell is gauss times
centimeters squared.
So, you know, the magnetic
field of the Earth
is about half a gauss.
A centimeter square
you can imagine.
And that's the value of
the flux quantum, which
will have a role later for us.